okay well first of all chloe kim
courtney it is so nice to meet you guys
you guys look beautiful and
congratulations on the new show so the
world thought that courtney and travis
eloped in vegas did any of you guys get
a heads up or have any reactions to this
news
i got a heads up i was on facetime for a
little bit i got to
talk with elvis for a second it was a
grand old time
i think we all got a few text messages
late night in the middle of the night
courtney you look like you're having the
time of your life and we're all like so
happy for you will we get to see this
wedding filmed on the show or is that
going to be a private thing
um there's no plans of it for now but we
also just are like getting married in
vegas and you know doing whatever feels
good
yeah um if you guys were to place your
bets who do you think will get engaged
next
i don't know you never know with our
family it could be like the most
unexpected person i don't know it
normally it's the most unexpected one
like this family is
crazy and we just fly by the seat of our
pants you never really know
we love it here we love it
[Laughter]
we do see a lot of courtney and travis
in the trailer but kim
how much will fans get to see of ump
i think you guys will definitely see my
perspective and you'll hear like you
know how we met and how it all went down
and like he's you know you'll see my
side of it when i'm on the phone and
stuff like that but um you know he
he's not opposed to being on or anything
like if he's with me and supporting me
and and with me at something but um it's
just not what he does and so he's so
busy working and filming that um we just
haven't had that opportunity
yet but um he's not opposed to it
yeah what kind of experiences will we
see of you
on the show this go-round
well i think it's just really
interesting that you get to see each of
us like so individual and so um it's
like a deeper look into what we do on a
daily basis and
to me that just feels super different
than
keeping up with the kardashians you know
where it was all of us together all the
time yeah so i'm excited for the viewer
to see that it just feels like super
documentary style yeah
chloe you've always worn your heart on
your sleeve and you're always so open
and honest about your challenges and i
know this this series we're talking
about your anxiety with the press and
dealing with trolls um you give great
life advice so what would be your mantra
for dealing with trolls let's go around
i mean i
give great advice but sometimes it's
hard to take and
really use your own advice that you so
freely give but
yeah i mean
it would be to drown out the noise but
that's so much easier said than done and
sometimes you're in it and you just feel
so consumed or that you're in this
hurricane of
just trash and there's days that i feel
super strong and i'm like f everyone and
you don't know me and i feel super good
and then there's days that i think it's
just too much for someone to handle and
i don't want to leave my house and i
can't look at my phone and go online so
it depends on the day and i think that's
really what anxiety is and that's okay
it's okay to be really honest and say
that not every day you feel good and not
every day you feel strong and that you
can handle it there's
two sides to everything and i think it's
fair for the public to see the good as
well as the bad
yeah i love that um there's been a lot
of reflecting on this series from where
you guys started and where you guys are
now there's been so much amazing things
that have happened if you could write
your own future what would it look like
10 years from now
oh my gosh i don't even know if that's a
fair question because i don't think we
would be able to write what's happening
right now i think
the beauty about life is that so much of
it is unexpected yeah the beauty about
life is that you never know what
tomorrow's going to lead and whether
that be
sad or happy i think that's just what
life is about and that's how you know
you're alive is that you're constantly
feeling new things yeah
and it's
yeah that is you're killing it um if you
could go back to the very beginning and
give yourselves some advice what is one
thing you would say to each other
i would just say like enjoy the ride
have fun look up look up from your phone
look out the window look at what he's
gonna say just be present
because all of this goes it's so
fleeting and it goes by so quickly and
someone said you guys weren't at the
dinner we were at last night but said a
good quote it's not about the
destination or the journey but it's
about the company
and
on that journey and that's so true and
so we got some badass company i'm i'm
happy
awesome thank you ladies thank you